bei mir im studio begrüße ich ganz
herzlich gerd landsberg herzlich
willkommen landsberg sind
hauptgeschäftsführer vom deutschen
städte und gemeindebund ich kann mir
vorstellen das ist so eine richtige
kampfzone also wenn es vom bund länder
gesprächen runter sichert auf städte und
gemeinden da knallt auch mit den bürgern
bis ihre einschätzung jetzt zu corona
knallt das wirklich so ist das relativ
im konsens also ich hoffe mal nicht dass
es knallt aber es ist richtig die können
jetzt in berlin beschließen was sie
wollen umsetzen müssen dass die städte
und gemeinden und den frust oder auch
die zustimmung der bürger denen erleben
wir vor ort und bisher ist es schon
immer einen großen konsens gelaufen das
hat viele gespräche auch mit der
bundeskanzlerin und den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden gegeben wir ziehen da
schon an einem strang und auch in die
gleiche richtung aber was uns ein
bisschen sorge macht und das könnte ja
auch heute wieder eine rolle spielen der
werden hier sehr fein regelungen erdacht
wie man etwas noch schärfer machen kann
es muss ja alles ander kontrollieren ich
sage immer macht nichts was wir nicht
kontrollieren können also appell ist gut
wir brauchen die akzeptanz der menschen
denen die bürger das nicht mehr
verstehen und sagen was gilt denn jetzt
einen die mit wem darf ich nicht treffen
die oma darf zum enkel mit den eltern
kommen aber umgekehrt dürfen die eltern
mit dem enkel nicht zur oma es sitzen
aber immer die gleichen leute am ende in
einem zimmer
all das ist nur so ein beispiel da gibt
es viele und wir merken natürlich schon
auch dass die bevölkerung ein bisschen
müde ist also auch was eben im
vorbericht gezeigt wurde
die bewegungsdaten vom märz und den
bewegungsdaten jetzt ja dass die
unterschiedlich sind ist doch ganz
logisch im märz haben wir die produktion
runtergefahren
jetzt haben wir produktion und wer
produzieren will muss im gewissen umfang
natürlich auch zu seiner arbeitsstätte
insofern ist das für mich erklärbar die
disziplin der leute ist groß aber was
sie erwarten ist in hoffnungssignal so
eine simple aussage zum beispiel zu
sagen also wenn im moment aber das nicht
wenn in einer stadt die inzidenz als
aber bei 40 ist dann könnt ihr wieder
essen gehen werden könnte zum verhör
geben oder ähnliches das finde ich schon
ganz gut auch wenn man jetzt nicht sagen
kann wann das kommt aber die menschen
hoffen auf die impfung und sie hoffen
auf ein normales leben und auch das muss
politik berücksichtigt verstehe ich sie
da richtig also gibt den alten satz gibt
zwei arten ein esel voranzutreiben
der route von hinten oder mit der
karotte von vorne ihnen wer lieber es
würden mehr sage ich mal fort mit der
karotte von vorne statements aus berlin
heute kommen nach dem motto wenn ihr bei
40 sei dann ist friseur wieder möglich
ich werde das mit der karotte gut also
wir müssen vermeiden dass die menschen
das gefühl haben vater staat sagt ein
untertan was sie zu machen namen und dem
feld jeden tag was neues also dass der
lok dann verlängert werden muss ist
völlig in ordnung beispiel masken woher
kommt der begriff mund und nase bedecken
der in der verordnung steht die ist doch
geschaffen wurde in einem zeitpunkt wo
es gar keine masten gab deswegen hat man
das auch so gemacht und gesagt du kannst
ein schal oder ein taschentuch oder
ähnliches nehmen also da wäre es schon
sinnvoll zu sagen also medizinische
masten fb2 ob wir die so flächendeckend
haben weiß ich nicht das wäre sinnvoll
im öpnv und vielleicht auch beim
einkaufen aber auch da wir wissen doch
wem ich wir wissen nicht ob zum beispiel
busse und bahnen treiber sind es gibt
untersuchungen der deutschen bahn wir
haben gesagt also eigentlich ist das gar
nicht ja und meine persönliche
wahrnehmung sowohl hier in bonn aber
auch in berlin
die masse buch von bussen und bahnen die
sie noch nicht mal halb voll also dass
die nun das treiben das ist mir
jedenfalls so nicht nachvollziehbar wenn
sie heute beraten können wenn einer der
und ländervertreter jetzt zu schaut was
würden sie den ins gebetbuch schreiben
also ich würde sagen verlängert das
erklärt das erklärt immer erklärt auch
wovor er angst hat sie haben ja angst
vor der mutation her und sagt den
menschen wir kontrollieren jetzt die
positiven test ob das eine mutation ist
und wir sagen euch es gibt eine zukunft
wir beschleunigen die impfung da ist
meiner ansicht ja wir müssen sehen dass
möglichst schnell die hausärzte impfen
können dann geht das ganze schneller
die hausärzte in deutschland haben
letztes jahr über 20 millionen menschen
also gegen grill geben ja und ich glaube
solche hoffnungssignale muss man sehen
und nicht immer sagen was nicht geht und
noch ein programms wichtig es wird in
diesem land unterschiedlich sein und das
halte ich für richtig
also viele menschen haben ja immer so
die sehen es auch die kanzlerin muss das
machtwort sprechen und dann ist das also
von hamburg bis berlin
die situation ist unterschiedlich wir
haben eine ganz andere situation sagen
wir mal wenn sie bonn vergleichen mit
thüringen da sind wir sehr viel stehen
wir besser da in schleswig-holstein
nähern sich jetzt einige schon wieder
der 50
54 also das wird differenziert sein und
dann wirklich noch warten
denkt an die eltern lasst kitas und
schulen jedenfalls im notbetrieb auf
wenn das ist eine herausforderung seit
märz geht das mit unterbrechung wenn sie
waren 23 kinder haben die noch
gleichzeitig fernunterricht und dann
sollen auch arbeiten im home office
das ist nicht zu schaffen und das wir
fahren die leute damit sei also eine
notbetreuung sollte es in der schule
aber auch im kindergarten geben sie
haben ja auch als städte und
gemeindebund tag fiel aus ein blick in
die indy breitbandausbau vor vor wenigen
jahren
jetzt haben wir die situation nehmen wir
das thema schulen haben einen sohn zu
hause der ist ein erster klasse hat
homeschooling der meldet sich über die
apple app dann an und dann sitzt er da
und mal hebt den finger
aber das problem ist auch dass die
kapazitäten hintendran noch nicht
ausgebaut sind also da schlecht
sozusagen die fehlende digitalisierung
nieder nicht also die digitalisierung
der schulen ist vorangegangen aber sie
ist bei weitem nicht am ziel
es wäre vielleicht ja auch sinnvoller
wenn in der kultusministerkonferenz man
mal sagen würde wir einigen uns auf eine
schul plattform das muss ein großer
anbieter seiten jedes land macht etwas
eigenes und in nützt die der tollste
digital unterrichts nicht wenn sie weder
die scheine auch zu hause das netz haben
also die botschaft digitales netz bis
zur letzten milchkanne ist vielleicht
übertrieben aber bis zum letzten gehöft
wäre wichtig und es hat sich in der
pandemie gezeigt dass das vielleicht
wichtiger ist als wir noch vor einem
jahr gedacht haben man muss fairerweise
sagen der bund hat eine menge geld zur
verfügung gestellt 4,5 milliarden
digital packt schule die aber weitgehend
noch nicht abgerufen sind ja das muss
ausgeschrieben oder die menschen sagen
das muss ganz schnell gehen aber schnell
ist eben auch schwierig ja noch ja und
ich frage den hauptgeschäftsführer vom
deutschen städte und gemeindebund was
ist ihre einschätzung zum home office
also home of ist es wichtig wie die
kommunen machen das so weit es möglich
ist wenn sie im personalausweis abholen
wollen da muss einer sein der ideen gibt
wir haben eine quote
das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich von
40% und ich habe bedenken eine home
office pflicht zu formulieren damit sind
wir wieder bei dem thema von eben wer
soll das eigentlich kontrollieren
im fernglas vorbeigehen das bringt doch
nicht die arbeitsabläufe sind sehr
unterschiedlich und ich kann aus meinem
eigenen verband sagen es gibt menschen
die gehen auch mal ganz gern ins büro
ist ja nicht so dass die leute alle
nicht ins büro
die werden eben mal kontakt haben sie
können nur ins hingehen also dann lieber
über den flur mit dem kollegen sich mal
unterhalten was ich für sinnvoll hielte
das ist nicht in allen bundesländern das
jedenfalls wenn mehrere in einem raum
zusammen sitzen das dann auch während
der arbeit masken pflicht bestehen aber
wenn in einem büro jeder seinen eigenen
raum hat und allenfalls über den flur
mit ihm redet sehe ich da keine gefahr
und wie gesagt eine pflicht kann man
natürlich machen aber ich frage wer soll
das kontrollieren
da kommen dann auch meistens keine
antwort das heißt die zur rede zur
debatte stehende pflicht eventuell die
unternehmen zu verpflichten dass sie
begründen warum jemand ins büro muss ist
auch also ich glaube ich eben doch ein
hohes interesse dass ihre mitarbeiter
gesund sind also wenn jemand kommt und
sagt ich kann das wirklich gut chef zu
hause machen
da glaube ich in der jetzigen situation
dass also die ganz ganz große mehr als
sagt ok macht das von zu hause also
dieses gefühl wird zu hause ist er
arbeitet nicht richtig
das haben wir abgelegt sie waren ja
selbst lange jahre richter am gericht
will ist es dafür richter zum beispiel
ich habe als richter schon früher ohne
corona fast ausschließlich zu hause
gearbeitet weil damals die justiz so
schlecht ausgestattet war dass wir mit
drei richtern in einem raum saßen man
konnte also keine zeugen davon nehmen
musste war anders geht
das war über ist für das zusammenspiel
mit den kollegen super aber für die
arbeiten ist schlecht was ist mit den
meldeämtern die müssen ja wir sagen ja
immer wir müssen auf instanzen von 50
und niedriger kommen damit die
gesundheitsämter auch wieder hinterher
kommen überhaupt das zu machen geht
sowas auch im home office das
größtenteils nicht im home-office weil
sie zugriff auf sensible daten haben
müssen da gibt es schutzvorschriften das
geht nicht aber die gesundheitsämter
werden viel besser es gibt ja inzwischen
ein digitalisierungs programm so war es
heißt das dass haben schon über 100 also
wird nicht mehr gefasst das gibt es
immer noch aber es liegt auch daran wer
hat sich denn früher für ein
gesundheitsamt interessiert sein einsatz
galt der grundsatz 08 15 gesundheitsamt
0 karrierechancen acht stunden arbeit
und höchstens 15 das ist heute etwas
anders auf einmal stehen im mittelpunkt
und jetzt werden die aufgerüstet das ist
gut so und da kommen wir voran aber auch
dass auch zeit dass die kirche als
systemrelevant auf schöne dollar wort
systemrelevanz wo glauben sie kann der
städte und gemeindebund beitragen dass
corona irgendwann mal geschichte ist wo
geht noch was wo können die städte auch
noch aktiver werden vielleicht auch fünf
schwiegervater hätte gesagt vom kleinen
toto also dass es viel geld kostet also
entscheidend ist dass die städte eine
kommunikations auftrag haben ein
bürgermeister oder eine bürgermeisterin
müssen den bürgern immer wieder
vermitteln warum mach ich was denn viele
kommunalen regelung sind ja noch viel
strenger als auf der bundesebene was
will ich damit erreichen und das immer
wieder und natürlich auch kontrolle
organisieren es gibt keine regelungen
die ihr wirksam ist wenn sie nicht auch
kontrolliert wird das ist vernünftig
aber die hauptauftrag ist kommunikation
mit den menschen zu sagen wir schaffen
das gemeinsam auch wenn das jetzt
abgelöscht klingt das ist schon wichtig
die karotte von vorne mit karotten der
bilanzwert ganz herzlichen dank für
diese erfrischenden einblicke auch vom
städte und gemeindebund muss ich sagen
nicht tag bund und auch für diesen
ausblick im konstruktiven sinne
herzlichen dank auch nicht im studio war